tonight we're joined by dr. Cornel West
one of America's most gifted and
provocative public intellectuals his
work has been described as a polemical
weapon that attempts to transform
linguistic social cultural and political
traditions to increase the scope of
individual in development and democratic
actions his best-selling book race
matters was published in 1993 and has
sold over 400,000 copies in his sequel
democracy matters West argues that
American democracy is threatened by free
market fundamentalism aggressive
militarism and escalating
authoritarianism if America is to become
a better steward of democratization
around the world he says we must first
wake up to the long history of
imperialist corruption that has plagued
your own democracy dr. West is a
university professor at Princeton
University he's also taught at Princeton
Yale and Harvard he holds degrees from
Yale Divinity School and Harvard
University won numerous awards and has
received more than 20 honorary degrees
please join me in welcoming dr. Cornel
West
[Applause]
thank you so very much I'm so very glad
very glad to be here I'd like to thank
my dear friend and sister Erin bringing
for those very kind and generous words
one of the dynamic students here at
Claremont McKenna College from Tacoma
I'm totally just spent wonderful time in
the Caribbean with Cuba in Cuba and
deeply appreciate your company I'd like
to thank my dear friend the new
professor here so very glad to see him
professor Adam Bradley he spent time
with me at Harbor let's give him a hand
so glad to see you nobody indeed indeed
I'll say that they are blessed to have
you and you were blessed to be here this
is a very very very special place and
similarly so for sister Kristen Kelly
from Sacramento who spent at a time it's
been a year here from Spellman where is
great where is Kristen there she is just
wave a little bit let's give her a hand
from Spelman College it's so nice to
have the connection of the historic
institution of Spelman College here with
this historic institution of Claremont
McKenna College and last but not least I
would like to pay tribute to a very very
special friend I've known her now for
over ten years I'm talking about Bonnie
snored him where is she where is Bonnie
where is Bonnie she's a director go all
the way in the back all the way in the
back
he's been the director now this grand
series and appreciating what each and
every one of you coming out tonight I
hope I say something that thoroughly
unsettles you
it's impossible to talk about democracy
matters without beginning on a Socratic
note and trying to get us to take
seriously at line 38 a and Plato's
apology the unexamined life is not worth
living to come against the grain of the
deep anti-intellectualism in a
market-driven civilization to take
seriously life of the mine and the world
of ideas and actually to proceed very
cautiously and carefully in that line
the unexamined life is not a life for
the human you know English word human
derives from the Latin who mundo which
means burying and we have featherless
two-legged linguistically conscious
creatures born between urine and feces
that's us
who often bury our dead as did Antigone
attempt to do with her son why because
we know in the end we are connected in a
fundamental way not just to the earth
the humic with terms humility and
humanity but we connect the past the
present and the future and there is no
way a democracy so fragile usually
short-lived in human history and human
history usually characterized
disproportionately with bestiality
barbarity atrocities the Socratic energy
robust debate uninhibited critical
exchange to shatter our varieties of
parochialism prevention
lism fundamentalism holding on for dear
life of certain kinds of certainties and
securities and yet refusing to come to
terms with the caduceus Eve life which
is to say the frailty and contingency of
it and what's so wonderful about
Socrates was what not just that he was
an exemplary democratic citizen but
rather because he knew that he did not
possess wisdom he was part of an endless
ceaseless pursuit of wisdom my Tech's
democracy matters begins and on this
Greek creation of Socratic questioning
do we really have what it takes to
engage in that kind of painful self
scrutiny in our move from womb to tomb
it raises the question who are we really
when we take the mask off what kind of
nation are we really when we push back
the various lies we often tell about
ourselves past and present it's not a
trashing of ourselves not a tracing of a
nation it's just trying to be honest and
candid that's what one loves about
Socrates and that's why Socratic
questioning is a precondition for any
serious discussion of democracy matters
dogmas as sister Erin mentioned earlier
dog was like free market fundamentalism
the kind of fetishizing of the
unregulated market as if it has some
magic independent of the quality of the
persons who inhabit those markets beyond
edited market as if it has some salvific
effect
independent of the ability of citizens
to ensure that it is regulated in light
of public interest and common good it's
hard to talk about these issues these
days was the mantra deregulate privatize
social security public education prisons
these are the managers of the last 30
years it becomes so dogmatically assumed
and presuppose that we lose sight of
what some of the effects are 1% of the
population owning 48% of the net
financial wealth and yet 20% of the
children in the richest nation in the
history of the world children of all
colors in the United States living in
utter poverty 39 percent of brown
children 37 percent of black children 46
percent of red children let us never
forget our indigenous brothers and
sisters but old brother Wes that's how
the market functions there's no such
thing as the market functioning these
are human beings contesting one another
markets our legal constructs they're
human creations they can do wonderful
things I was just at Microsoft last week
it's fairly clear it can do wonderful
things that generate unbelievable levels
of efficiency productivity allowing
levels of communication unprecedented at
the same time you can generate isolation
and unequality inequality that will
undermine any fragile democratic project
where is the dialog well we look mr.
Bush what do we hear right now both of
them seem to be in the gutter right we
don't even have a public discussion
Swift boat on one side and whether Bush
served adequately on the other side can
we get out of the gutter and have a
public conversation about the wealth
distribution and why it is that so much
of the wealth have been going from poor
and working people to well-to-do in the
last 15 years and I was before the tax
cuts tax cuts kicking even more so and
yet it's become so fashionable to be in
solidarity with the well-to-do even as
we look at the decrepit schools 47
million fellow citizens have no access
to health care whatsoever mother's
father's not having access to child care
not enough jobs with the living wage and
the loss of jobs and the Bush
administration is not solely a Bush
responsibility though it is in part of
Bush responsibility but as a system at
work the same wealth inequality with
occurring under clinton especially given
the telecommunications act and specially
given the welfare reform bill that he's
so proud of and mr. Kerry is so proud of
to be socratic is to do what not only
think outside of the box but to respect
fellow citizens enough to tell them the
truth to tell them the truth is it
through Socratic lens when I see what's
going on in Washington reminds me
through Symmachus and Plato's Republic
might makes right it's a mockery of
integrity and truth
we have the power we exercise it and
explain later or change explanations
later you see we have the might we do it
look at mr. Carey reminds me in some
ways a Grand Inquisitor of those gypsies
great classic of 1880 you see I'll deal
with a system that's corrupt I know that
Washington is in part characterized by
legalized bribery and normalized
corruption and institutionalized graft
but I can do some wonderful things
inside of it anyway and he's right you
have to work with what you got but why
don't you begin Socratic li tale fellow
citizens the truth tell them that we're
at the point at which the system has
become so saturated with big money that
the politicians no longer able to speak
their minds or actually find their
voices because they're encircled by
spinsters and pollsters and others who
are checking to see what their deepest
commitments are after they've engaged in
some poll and why it is it so many
fellow citizens disengaged disillusion
it looks as if even this election one of
the most important elections in the
history of American Republic the
majority of American citizens who can
vote will not I was just on the other
night with brother Sean Hannity but a
wonderful exchange I appreciate his
energy and never convinced by his
arguments for the most part no but he is
my brother not my comrade but my brother
he said he said brother Wes it's a
wonderful thing that American citizens
don't vote right he said they're lazy
and he says if they wanted to vote they
would but we're after ones who do vote I
said well I'll take American citizens
more seriously than that I travel around
the country I believe American people
are full of tremendous creativity
intelligence and imagination so when
they decide to vote I might think
they're short-sighted I don't think
they're stupid I don't think they're
lazy then we have to raise some Socratic
questions maybe they're saying something
that those of us who are involved don't
want to hear what does it mean to be
depoliticized in a market culture that
convinces you to be political is to be
locked into market-driven politics that
have no serious substantive Socratic
dialogue or public exchange anyway maybe
they're tired of the infomercials that
they see when you when they convene in
conventions and so forth or maybe there
also are so frightened about their own
private lies because the appeal to fear
and greed that is becoming more and more
characteristic of our political
discourse is something that turns them
off even as they try to cultivate their
own private istic garden reminding one
of Voltaire's Candide aren't we - listen
maybe in fact these vas are not vast but
the majority of American citizen 51%
maybe they have kids in Iraq and
Afghanistan right the army of the
American Empire at this moment is
disproportionately lower middle-class
working-class black brown and maybe
they're convinced that the
rationalizations haven't been persuasive
but they're still pulling for the best
for their own kids and for the American
armed forces
you see but they refuse to participate
and what they believe to be a rather
superficial process these are all
questions but serious questions and
where is a debate the dogma free-market
fundamentalism tied to the dogma of
aggressive militarism doctrines of
pre-emptive strikes inseparable from the
doctrine of escalating authoritarianism
sure many of you have heard the case of
brother Tariq Ramadan the University of
Notre Dame you have following a case
here you have a Islamic intellectual 21
Tech's critical of all forms of Islamic
terrorism himself wrestling with a
relation between democracy and Islam how
do you conceive of democracy within
Islamic traditions within Islamic terms
because Islam is here to stay and the
question is how do you democratize those
autocratic oil-rich usually anti-semitic
Arab states and how do you socrata is
Islam Christianity had the same
challenge Judaism had the same challenge
what Tarak brother Ramadan is raising
this question at university Notre Dame
had asked him to teach he said yes you
know University knew that Notre Dame
institution of great standing and
integrity ready to bring him over enroll
his children in class but he was yet to
fly over from Switzerland and the Bush
administration canceled his visa no
reason given sending chills through the
debate about the Middle East
chills over how does one engage in a
dialogue mediated with civility and
mutual respect on one of the most
delicate and difficult issues of the
israeli-palestinian conflict what kind
of dog was are we willing to interrogate
can we take seriously the precious
security of I hated people like Jews in
Israeli state
having people intending to push them
into the C&I elate them and yet at the
same time can they ever ever have
security if they are occupying a people
subjugating of people where is a debate
in the nation hardly at all no democracy
can survive the great John Dewey used to
say when citizens lose the art of
dialogue is name-calling and
finger-pointing and mudslinging there is
no movement or motion for any proximate
solution because democracies in the end
are proximate solutions to insoluble
problems the gray Reinhold Niebuhr used
to say that and he's absolutely right
that's why anybody who believes in
utopia is living in a different world no
such thing use most promoters from those
most of those who promote utopianism
have an authoritarian gender anyway
because they figure they have the truth
and they're gonna impose it on others
that's what's so frightening about some
of my fellow Christians these days
disproportionately on the right they
figure they've got the truth put the
commandments in the public space well I
thought the first one was thou shalt
have no other gods before me but about
idolatry what kind of critique proceeds
from imposing your views on fellow
citizens be they set your agnostic
Buddhist Jewish and so on or is it the
case and we saw this with the Mel Gibson
film is it the case that the dominant
forms of American Christianity have
become Constantinian Christianity so
deferential to the Empire preoccupied
with those the prayer fineö of the
Empire which is what
our confusing gigantis ism with
greatness might there's no accident that
the movement of these megachurches in
American Christianity in which the
pastors and more CEOs and the Gospels
become prosperity Gospels and the
prayers become let's make a deal with
God a spear my wheel of fortune waiting
for my blessing that's Constantinian
Christianity and how ironic that
Constantine the Emperor who converted to
Christianity in 312 decriminalized
Christianity as a religion in 313 with
the Edict of Milan and his successor
Theodosius the first would incorporate
Christianity as the official religion of
the Roman Empire yet this was a Roman
Empire did put Jesus to death the
Nightside of the Roman Empire is a cross
that's what happened to courageous
sacrificial Jewish leaders who were
willing to present a threat and
challenge to the Roman Empire even if
the subordinate Jewish elites who were
always under the Roman Empire would go
along and with brother Mel Gibson didn't
grasp that these Roman elites were not
like Marcus Aurelius involved in
contemplation and meditation Pontius
Pilate was a gangster he was a thug he
killed hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of Jews and therefore Roman
responsibility along with Jewish
deference not Jewish responsibilities
alongside either Roman innocence or
Roman contemplatively leach unsure about
which way to go why is that important
it's very important because we live at a
moment in which Constantinian Christians
many of whom most of whom are very
sincere and very pietistic but whose
conception of Jesus who is the victim of
a Roman Empire doesn't lead them to
look for the night side of the American
Empire doesn't lead them to look for the
the underside of the American Empire to
cut against that grain wells you can
imagine that my Texan part is an attempt
to make the world safe for the legacy of
Martin Luther King jr. Fannie Lou Hamer
white brother like Myles Horton Jewish
brothers like Rabbi Abraham Joshua
Heschel white sisters like Doris Day
Dorothy - and say Doris Day Dorothy Day
when the founders of the great Catholic
social movement and so forth and what do
you mean brother what make the world
safe for them to ensure that the Greek
invention of Socratic questioning is
inseparable from the Jewish creation of
prophetic witness but it proverbs 14 31
rings loud he who oppresses the poor
insults ones maker he who is in
solidarity with the poor elevates ones
maker what a criteria for contemporary
Constantinian Christians some people say
well I'm voting for somebody because
they're Christian how do you define it
are they Constantinian are they
prophetic are they linked to the powers
that be in in some non Socratic way not
willing to raise the deep questions and
simply mouthing pietistic cliches and
shibboleths that are connected with
christian rhetoric or the mustering
occur it's not simply to think
critically for themselves but also the
courage to care for the least of these
and of course one don't have to go
through a math fifth chapter let justice
run down like waters and righteousness
like a mighty stream wouldn't go on and
on Micah 6:8 to justly love mercy walk
humbly with thy God and this is not
narrow religious language you see
because the Jewish creation of the
prophetic was one of the great moments
in the history
dream of humankind because it was in no
way confined to just Jewish people it
said to be human is to be kind to the
stranger to keep your focus on those who
are rendered invisible and it will serve
as a standard for all nations and how
difficult it is these days to see the
cross elevated over the flag as opposed
to the flag itself higher than the cross
and the cross deferential to the flag
one in which patriotism itself becomes
idolatrous rather than concomitant with
a deeper prophetic commitment to justice
all across the board and my hunter the
American people do have a sense of the
levels of hypocrisy and mendacity when
it comes to using idolatry as a
measuring point Sodom Hussein installed
by the CIA
I mean marching against him in 1980
donald rumsfeld rumsfeld shakes his hand
in 1983 under reagan any word about
kurds no any words about liberation of
iraqi women no any words about
liberation iraqi people as a whole
no oh you change your mind lately huh oh
god believe i'm Socratic people can't
change their mind that's wonderful but
let's be honest what is going on
Saudi Arabia Morocco autocratic women
can't drive can't walk around dressed in
the way in which these sisters of all
colors here are but we're on the cutting
edge of feminist concerns about
liberation women oh sorry raven have
artichokes to have a well i see very
different US foreign policy at work here
indonesia gangsters been
running it even China dictator still
running the political State suppressing
dissents and detractors but the market
is expanding and American business can't
wait to get deeper into it let's just be
honest about it no one of us have any
monopoly on consistency but if we're
inconsistent let us point it out among
each other as fellow citizens and fellow
human beings but let us look at it
through the vantage point of this deep
commitment to justice which means when
one begins with the most vulnerable
there's always a danger you see when you
talk this way in America they say well
you know it's titillating and
stimulating but it's really just a
rhetoric because when it really comes
down we've got the deeply conservative
Republicans who appear to many they're
being mean-spirited and cold-hearted and
we got the milk taupe Democrats who
can't wake up and find their voice and
don't know whether they ought to
triangulate the Republicans or try to
find their sense of who they are given a
distance from the legacy of FDR and the
New Deal what a choice not a choice and
there is a deep sense in which I that
most of you know I resonate with many of
the insights of my dear brother Ralph
Nader and I pray Forman won't vote for
him this time that's just footnote
but he presents a challenge a serious
challenge has no monopoly on truth but
my god he's got some serious analysis
when it comes to corporate power here
and around the world and how plutocratic
and Oleg are kickin to some degree
pigment o Craddock corporate elites are
here and around the world in an all
honesty 9/11 has changed things I think
the President Bush is right about that
it hasn't changed everything but has
changed things I'm slowly convinced that
we living at a moment of deep crisis and
emergency before 9/11 when I looked at
condition of young people condition of
working people but after 9/11 never
before in the history of this country
have all Americans felt unsafe
unprotected subject to random violence
and hate it new condition many of my
white brother and sisters walk up to me
so you know brother Wes I just can't get
over this sense of being hated it's a
new experience
I say you don't say really because of
course to be a [ __ ] in America for 350
years up until the 1960s was to be
unsafe unprotected subject to random
violence and hate head now the whole
nations [ __ ] rised this is a feeling of
a certain kind of helplessness a certain
sense that you're not in control a
certain sense that you can't push a
button for overnight solution a sense
that maybe your optimism was to Disney
World like I know I'm in LA I didn't say
that intentionally but it's not Peter
Pan and not Forever Young locked into
some narrow sophomoric discourse of
innocence a melodramatic story that says
all the goods on one side and all the
evils on the other and the villains are
impure and the heroes are pure maybe in
fact the Socratic questioning and the
prophetic witness needs to take
seriously the black creation of the
blues the tragic comic hope that says we
have been through terrorism the
materials mother what do you say to your
child your only child who went down to
Mississippi in August of 1955 and found
his body in the Tallahatchie River you
have to say something to the world and
responding to terrorism and you recall
that historic moment in Chicago in 1955
when she allowed her baby here only baby
as I noted to lie before the pulpit and
to keep the coffin open 50,000 fellow
citizens march to to see this victim of
American terrorism his head was five
times the size of his ordinary head
what did she say when she stepped to the
lectern I don't have a minute to hate
I'll pursue justice for the rest of my
life there's a level of moral maturity
and spiritual strength that come through
a blue Sensibility a tragic comic hope
in which you can steal somehow muster a
smile in the midst of such darkness and
not stoop to the gutter of revenge and
resentment and bitterness that
completely eats up your soul brother
Martin did the same thing when he had to
speak to four young sisters in
Birmingham when American terrorists
killed those innocent fellow citizens
you all are too young to remember one of
the few times brother Martin had tears
in his eyes in public because he didn't
know what to say he looked into the eyes
of the parents as they were crying just
as all of us shared tears responding to
our fellow citizens and fellow human
beings 9/11 weather him no matter what
color they were Martin what do you have
to say he says somehow we must master we
must come up with a language that
deploys the armor of love and justice
what a standard set when we look at the
dominant responses to American terrorism
the dominant responses to [ __ ] ization
since 9/11 revenge I'm down like
cockroaches machismo identities Lone
Ranger sensibilities it falls far short
of the standard set by a materials
mother and the standard set by Martin
King Martin Luther King jr. this text in
part raises the question can a blues
nation learn from
blues people not because black folk have
any monopoly on democracy matters but
rather because when it comes to raising
Socratic questions of dogma especially
white supremacy and wealth inequality
when it comes to prophetic witness
Frederick Douglass tella Baker when it
comes to blues Lee Roy Carr
moire nyan Bessie Smith John Coltrane
the alone is month these aren't just
musicians these are practitioners of
democratic individuality who in their
improvisational arts and in their
experimental lives provide an exemplary
form of democracy in action and it's an
instant question the real sense in which
may be the very cornerstone that was
kicked aside rendered invisible can now
come back and provide some vision and
analysis and hope to keep this fragile
experience in democracy alive it's an
open question let's see together what we
can do thank you all so very much
hi dr. Wes thanks for coming out today
you gave very entertaining speech yeah I
was wondering if you could discuss your
solutions to the dogmatic free-market
fundamentalism yes I think that the I
appreciate you say an entertainment
amine and a sense of horace that it both
delighted as well as instructed as I
appreciate that oh brother I'm just
playing with but uh there's no solution
the alternative is that there ought to
be regulations of markets that are just
that ensure that markets do not
undermine common good and public
interest and what that means it's
keeping track of corporate greed what
that means is having some accountability
of elite especially at the top from CEOs
across the board ensuring that workers
are on track in fact treated fairly
ensuring that workers do in fact have
the right to engage in collective
bargaining which is American law since
eighteen since 1936 and so forth and so
on
so that what I'm talking about in part
is how do we constitute strong
countervailing institutional structures
of accountability visa avi unregulated
relatively unregulated unfettered
unedited markets so in this it's not
really a thrashing of markets you can
see we've reached the point where the
markets have become so deregulated and
it's clear they can't regulate
themselves and it's clear that there are
things call SiC markets that's what
health care is all about it's a sick
market it doesn't work and it's a matter
of life and death of millions of fellow
citizens the market mechanism that
generates efficiency and productivity
doesn't work in certain things
supermarkets it might work even though
the Walmarts is a challenge but but
healthcare doesn't you have to have some
countervailing forces now of course
oftentimes you know right-wing
brothers/sisters want to say well if
you're not for unregulated market you
must be a communist but see that's
precisely the
manichaean us-versus-them approach that
trumps in
a serious public discussion because
you're always talking about forms of
imperfection and gradation and balance
of forces so it's never just one or the
other you see and it and yet even a
Democratic Party has trouble in this
dialogue base over NAFTA we can talk
about other other instances in this
regard this is again what the voice not
just a Ralph Nader but a Sheldon Wolin
of Wendy Brown when you're Grider and
whole host of other thinkers in this
regard become variable other queries way
in the back of you oh there we go yes
yes dr. west I just wanted to say thank
you very much we are edified we are
honored and we are privileged to have
you here my question actually follows
quite closely to the last question and I
it's that I'm interested in hearing more
about what you think about self
cultivation and this kind of cultural
renewal I think you were talking about
in Chapter three of democracy matters
and my question is based on this the
concern is in in a liberal society like
ours yeah where there's just such a huge
plural right conception of the good and
of the good life right our citizens are
able to participate and compete with one
another without sharing a conception of
the good our institutions our political
social cultural institutions are
supported and sustained by wealth so
that you know it doesn't matter you know
what culture you espouse or you adhere
to or what your values are right you can
participate in this society but that
means that wealth and money becomes the
lowest common denominator of value so
it's no surprise that our culture is
kind of sucked into the gravity of that
but I was wondering if you'd say more
about limiting the the market on the one
hand but what is this self cultivation
that you're interested in and how does
that fit in with a multi multicultural
society like ours no I appreciate the
question of it's very challenging one
that third chapter where I deal with
what
I call the Emersonian tradition Ralph
Waldo Emerson the The Godfather of the
deep democratic tradition in the United
States and my dear friend and colleague
Jeff stout whose Magisterial text
democracy and tradition actually fleshes
this out in much more detail I mean he's
actually at Emersonian perfectionist in
the terms of rooted in Emerson's
commitment to thinking for yourself
trying to trust yourself relying on your
critical capacity acknowledging one of
the most difficult things in life as he
says in his essay intellect is to think
who so would be a man and we must add
woman woman he says is what a
nonconformist back to the first question
Ralph Waldo Emerson what do you mean
whoso be a man or woman would be a
nonconformist because you're gonna have
to cut through the cake of conformity
and complacency and cowardice and you
won't stoop the hatred cuz hatred is
nothing but the coward's revenge against
those who intimidate them you're not
going to be complacent because no
democracy can survive with a passive
citizenry and you're going to be true to
yourself because nothing is as sacred
but your mind operating right now that's
Emerson of course I didn't go on to talk
about Baldwin and I go on to talk about
Morrison why because there is a sense in
which as we know Socrates who never
wrote a word hey just like Jesus never
wrote a word but in the renders of
Socrates in the works of Plato Xenophon
and Eska knees we never see Socrates
shed a tear he never cries so given all
the commitment he has the critical
reflection something's wrong with
somebody's never shed a tear and James
Baldwin and Toni Morrison say it's not
just a matter of being nonconformist but
if you've never really shed a tear
you've never really loved you never
really love you never really lived in a
certain sense you see and to shed a tear
is to acknowledge that there's an agony
in an anguish of people struggling to be
self cultivated the ideal of noble self
mastery that we see in Socrates is
profound but insufficient because it
refuses
have a heartfelt solidarity with a
critical dimension we're the agony
language and agony and anguish of
oppressed people and it's there we're
Ballwin and it's there where Toni
Morrison coming on part of Herman
Melville are you in his text provide
that wedding of the socratic conception
of questioning and the Jewish creation
of prophetic witness that there has to
be some deep caring and anybody who ever
mustered the courage to care deeply to
be compassionate will in fact shed tears
and cry unlike Socrates who was
exemplary in his questioning but some
for some reason has a certain kind of
defect in his conception of Eros and
people have been wrestling with this Leo
Strauss is famous they think 58 lectures
on the problem of Socrates why doesn't
he cry he never laughs either but Jesus
doesn't either so that's another issue
he grins right before he dies he he
tries a smile can't get a full one
what's going on this is very interesting
very deep we know that Thomas More
wrestled with this in the Tower of
London right his his tribulation zone
why did Socrates never cry and Jesus
never laughed this is the great Catholic
Thomas More the author of utopia the
best friend of the greater ass mr.
translate evolution he never resolved at
all and part of my discussion of these
foundational commitments at this level
of Paideia self-cultivation that you're
referring to right as much to do with
fusing this questioning with the tears
and also with the blues the tragic comic
hope that has much to do with
transfiguring guttural cries and
wrenching moans into sustaining one's
life it's not just singing its own
sustaining one's life with dignity with
grace with swing as Elif is Geralyn Duke
would put it you see maybe Muhammad Ali
too would swing
they say being able to keep moving with
a certain kind of style knowing that you
can actually make a blow for justice
make a blow for critical consciousness
but in the end you're going to have to
pass it on to a younger generation and I
didn't get into my discussion about
Constantinian hip hop and prophetic hip
hop you see 50 cent versus Kanye West
you know I mean we got we got some real
contestation going on here in terms of
hip-hop that defers to the empire and
hip hop that tries to be truth-telling
the truck be the carrier's was the k RS
ones and nothing so forth other question
um respect dr. West oh yes sir
yes but I agree to nation is worth the
peace that's how I'm wallet India
alaikum hello my brother I guess sir dr.
wise that's someone who's a big family
you're a student of yours and following
your speeches and reading your books I
see is a role model to me as a human
being as well as a scholar in light of
that I kind of had troubled I wanted
States to in a public setting
sure but then I thought about the fact
you mention the Socratic method so I
figured unless in that spirit I'm going
to come at you with something that's one
which troubles me in your talk that's
one alone you don't talk about my mom
and everything to wonder oh my god I
know you wouldn't good you love me I
love you go right ahead but love for
moms all the way run yes sir so the
thing that told me is earlier in your
talk you kind of expanded upon it after
one of the questions but earlier in your
talk you uh you were talking about the
complicated matter of the Middle East
the situation yeah and in that talk you
talked about this situation of our
Jewish and Israeli brothers and sisters
and you talked about their fear
persecution and his fear of them being
hated the word was your word and being
pushed into the Red Sea annihilated
annihilated that's right which is very
much a common trope that we hear against
again I feel against my people and and
it's more problematic because coming
from you I see you as someone who kind
of like stands up for the for the rights
and fights through these stereotypes in
light of the current stereotypes of like
these Arabs and Muslims as these violent
people as these angry people uncritical
you know just murderous and on some
level doing a tremendous I felt in my
opinion no disrespect to the to the
great injustice
to the Palestinian people as if their
resistance to their oppressor is any way
different from the fight for justice
that black South Africans had against
their white oppressors that the
indigenous birth sisters of this country
had against their oppressors on and on
and on as if going back to 1948 in the
occupation of their land in light of you
writing about imperialism colonization
how their struggle against Western
appeals and colonization is any
different things and the struggles and
playing into the tropes to them being
these violent people who want as if
example the Iraqi resistance to u.s.
colonisation it's not about this anti
Western struggle or anti American it's
about we're freedom for their
independence on their land create their
own exact time socially and similarly in
Palestine their resistance isn't against
anti-semitism or gives Jewish people
it's a human response to any people have
for dignity and for justice no I
appreciate that question oh brother this
is precisely the kind of exchange that
we need and I appreciate you your
honesty in this regard because I mean
we're we're at a moment now I think in
the culture where you and I and a whole
host of others wrestling with this both
in public and in other places is going
to spin off in some very positive ways
because it is an issue we have to hit
head-on first thing is if that I only
talk about a slice of Palestinians a
slice of Muslims a slice of Islamic
brothers and sisters those ones that
call gangsters now when I say gangsters
I mean gangsters of those who kill
innocent people period now you can be a
part of a guerrilla Nelson Mandela was a
terrorist on your US government list for
over 25 years
then they celebrate him when he walks
out because they're hoping that he
doesn't turn on them the way they turned
on him
and he's a statesman about it right but
of course Nelson Mandela Nelson Mandela
in the spirit of nation spirit a nation
which was a violent group they were they
were targeting military they were
targeting bill they weren't killing
innocent civilians in any kind of
continuous way now we know this innocent
brothers and sisters on the west bank
who are killed by Israeli tanks that's
true
there's innocent Israeli brother sisters
who are killed by suicide
bombers or freedom fighters however you
want to characterize them but that to me
is gangsterism I'm against gangsterism
across-the-board chitta me black folk
kill innocent white folk that's gangster
activity white folk killing innocent
black folk yes against active question
of justice now that doesn't mean that
that downplays the heroic resistance of
any oppressed people in this case
Palestinian people who are occupied and
subjugated exactly what you see as you
know and it was very important that
Mohamed Gandhi's grandson was just there
a few weeks ago because Michael Lerner
and a number of us have been saying that
even at the level of Shir strategy when
you look at everyday ordinary heroic
Palestinians non-violently resisting can
there be a leadership to come out that
critiques the occupation but also calls
for some kind of non-violent witness
that will then win the contest even more
so of the world and then we see what the
response is because my hunch is you're
going to have a number of everyday
ordinary Israeli brothers and sisters
who are critical of shirome who would
look at this nonviolent Palestinian
witness and say my god we might have
some possibility of convergent and
that's precisely the direction that I'm
pushing so I want to make it clear to
you that even though I'm unequivocal in
my critique of gangsterism across the
board when Poli shoot down a black fella
in the chocolate city that's gangster
isn't to me that's the arbitrary use of
power of an innocent person well I
thought they had a gun it turned out to
be a popsicle
well okay I know judgment can be in air
sometime but god of money proceeded more
consciously
that's an innocent person across the
board death squads and El Salvador
disappeared forget it entertainer these
innocent folk so you see the point I'm
making even everywhere I go I'm going to
be highlighting a pro justice agenda and
an anti gangster identity no matter what
color they are and of course it has a
certain kind of Christian motivation but
and at the same time
fundamentally democratic one so my
hunters that we probably have more
overlap even though we're still wrestle
with some of the other details and so
and so forth good evening dr. West um I
was just curious um I'm afraid that my
question isn't his eloquent earns
complicated
honestly along with her tonight going to
take your time and ask it from your
heart mind and soul dope but okay I'm
saying it if you want it you know over
the past several months several years
and I'm sure will continue you know and
continuing and the months and years ago
fall there's been talk about um the
resurgence of drafts in the United
States and I was just curious how not
only how you felt about the concept of
draft but how you felt it sort of I
don't know mingled with your concept of
democracy in modern America that's my
question
yeah I appreciate that question Charles
Rangel and others have been raising this
question to brother and you were
actually quite eloquent I thought let's
give it a brother hand I thought you got
right to the point don't man
you got right to the point absolutely
that's what eloquence is wisdom speaking
in their words of Cicero and quintillion
up and there's a certain wisdom in the
question because it is a challenge I I'm
actually ambivalent about the question
because on the one hand I think that
public service especially among young
people is so important is indispensible
one of the things I loved about the
AmeriCorps program with the Clinton
administration I was very critical to
clean the administration on the rhibs
issue but the AmeriCorps on the Eli
Segal was magnificent because it didn't
require young people that tried to
persuade them that public service is
worth Wow
check it out it can change your life
you can become multi contextual not just
multicultural cuz you could be
multicultural and stay in a booze well
balloon I'm hanging out with my boo SWAT
Negros now my boo SWAT Browns my booze
my ribs my bourgeois yellows no no going
to the inter city go to white Appalachia
or white brothers and sisters kitchen
hey Allah go to the barrio in East Los
Angeles where the Browns brothers and
sisters catching hail that's just not
multiculturalism and some kind of
smugglers board and picnic eating
different kind of foods feeling spicy
and multi contextualism public service
will in fact military services are
species of public service that changes
your life not simply because you're
fighting an enemy you're interacting
with fellow citizens that you ordinarily
do not and in fact many white brothers
and sisters will have to get used to
taking orders from black and brown
officers they know more than you that's
a new experience for some white brothers
Jamal knows more than me yes he does
because he's brilliant
cuz he's sharp because he's better the
army for 20 years and you just got here
that reshapes your conception of how you
then look at Jamal's cousins and black
brothers who look like Jamal and so
forth and so on you see so on the other
hand I'm a little suspicious of a
compulsory draft because I just don't
like the idea of pushing citizens into
these things that's part of my
ambivalence you see now of course
Michael Moore who I think is an
exemplary citizen in many ways I really
do
I did I don't think he's got the truth
in any capital T even though he's got
some very important points to me up but
when he raised that question about one
young person out of all the children of
the 435 Congress men and women serving
in the armed services in Iraq and when I
go to black churches and ask how many
have relatives serving in Iraq 65
percent of hands go up something is
wrong something is wrong in terms of
who's bearing the cost of this
particular invasion occupation now I
guess it's kind of interim praise is
kind of logically projected independent
we don't know what to call it right now
even though it still a sense that US
military is calling the shots but they
are trying we have to push for all forms
of democratization I don't mind
coinciding with the Empire if they're
pushing for colonization I mean for
democratization but I was a slip
that was a slip you see because you've
got to be the fuse they have fusion and
fission sometimes you end up using wood
folk you to agree with other issues but
they're actually on the ball in this
case you see democratization can in fact
come in very uneven ways for the most
part I think it's part of a u.s.
Imperial pattern but at the same time we
have to deal with what we have and see
whether we can push the monetization no
matter what so there's your question is
I just don't know I really don't I am I
am ambivalent I want to read one set of
arguments it looks powerful I read
another set of arguments about coercing
and pushing folk it's hard to say what
what are you young people think do you
think you all ought to be drafted no now
those who you those of you who are pro
war are you willing to go fight the war
join the army to do it or is it just an
argument in the lounge there's a
question that's all mr. clay just a
question I mean I'm a Christian but no
pass I'm not a pacifist at all I would
have fought World War two against a
vicious fascist like Hitler even in a
white supremacist army like the US Army
the Jim Crow army that fought the racist
fascist Hitler just desegregated on me I
would have fought in that war I would
have fought in South Africa against
apartheid because every nonviolent
possibility was crushed by a narrow
autocratic set of white supremacist
elites who had constituted their hair
and folk democracy a democracy for
whites only they tried everything see
what why would I have fought with George
Washington and Thomas Jefferson like
Crispus Attucks he was the first one to
die black me I think I would have the
anti-imperialism was such that even
given the Imperial designs of what
Jefferson called the empire of Liberty
and America's rising Empire the language
of George Washington Reis of the
indigenous peoples I would have been a
multi contextual soldier I would have
fought against the British then I would
have fought against Americans
with the indian justice justice justice
justice each time that's the point
george the third year unjust US
government treating indigenous people
this way you're unjust which means i
would have been dead about 22 y'all
wouldn't have to worry about me one last
set of questions here um so it seems
that a sorry if I misinterpreted you or
anything but sure it seems that at the
heart of what we're chasing here is this
democratic justice a lot in the face of
such an apathetic constituency though
and like I all these people that you say
yourself are I don't know failing to
save themselves I guess I want to know
why like democracy is this Dogma that we
should be chasing in itself yeah I
appreciate the question though brother
because I may I begin with that last
important phrase democracy is dogma see
democracy is an ideal it's not a Dogma
because you don't possess it dog with
something you have when we talk about
Socrates wisdom is not something you
have it's something you're in pursuit of
when I said when I said democracy
doesn't solve all problems it's the best
proximate solution given the
insecurities and anxieties we have as
human beings it is an ideal and the
ideal is worth living for the ideal is
worth dying for
precisely because it is only when
ordinary people take back their power in
the face of elite abuse of power that
we're able to secure the reins for you
to ask that question I mean you know
there's a lot of places where you can
you ask the question right my
presentation would have been stopped the
first ten seconds going to jail I waive
that just never see me again
we laugh at that serious business China
Indochina Pakistan Saudi Arabia many
Latin American countries even steel you
see so that when we say why fight for
this Dogma it's because I like to hear
your voice expressed freely
sound good may not agree with the
argument all the time but we need each
other's voices that's what a democracy
is right is it's a way in which people
associate with one another by raising
their voices that's why the jazz quartet
as I've said before is a paradigm of
democratic symbolic action right if you
have the courage discipline and openness
to find your voice and lift it with the
Negro national anthem to lift the voice
over against other voices then maybe
we're better off in dealing with some of
our problems wealth inequality
ecological crisis and so forth you see
and I don't believe that one gives up
simply because a significant slice of
one's fellow citizens run out of gas and
become apathetic and cynical you have to
raise the question why are they
apathetic how do you get at them yet
don't give up on them see what I mean
you're forever trying to convince them
that it's worthwhile to bring their
voices in especially if they're
disciplined in the sense of being
informed willing to be both right and
wrong in the conversation and so forth
so that for me in the end is the most
importantly that's why I think she'll
the world is right when he says
democracy is more a mode of being and
cultural way of life than it is simply a
mode of governance which is to say it's
more verb than a noun it's a more verb
than a noun it's like Gertrude Stein she
democratized sentences how did she do it
she unsettled the conventional hierarchy
of predicates subject by putting the
verbs in the center and making it all
motion and movement Muriel Rukeyser did
that too towering poet that she wore the
adrià enriched and others how do you
ensure that this action is verbal
activity and not just a preoccupation
with the hierarchy of subject predicate
subject objects and I know it's getting
a little abstract and have to stand
philosophical but it's connected in a
fundamental way with remaining
concretely concerned about individuals
like yourself individuals like myself
your parents my parents all the parents
here
each one precious each one deserving of
a certain kind of concern that their
voices can be heard and every generation
is had to meet the challenge of keeping
the democratic tradition alive and you
don't keep a tradition alive by waiting
to inherit it you have to fight for it
or you lose it and your generation is
going to have to fight for it in your
own distinctive ways in one of the ways
I hope is of some small help and aid is
to wrestle with some of the things
talked about in the book especially
going back to to the Emerson's and the
DeMeo Veals intellectually in the ball
ones and and Morrison's intellectually
in the Kings and others politically and
of course debating one another civilly
not just over the election but what is
the destiny of the American democratic
project in the 21st century I know it's
getting very late and should we bring it
to a close you all think what do you
thinks is there and that is all the time
we are thank you very much though I
appreciate